meet Lobo who are you oh I'm sorry my
car he's basically a mash-up of Superman
of Wolverine an immortal unkillable
alien antihero that happens to have
super senses a crazy healing factor and
a love for beer and cigars both sounds
great right well not so much his big
expanse of waited years for Lobo to
makes the jump to the silver screen and
the success of 2016 r-rated Deadpool
seem to be proof that boar do comic book
characters would start heading to
theaters in short order but really
chances are pretty good that it just
won't happen I love you too here's why
DC and Warner Brothers will never give
Lobo his own movie parody problems the
most fundamental problem with creating a
Lobo movie is that Lobo is at heart a
parody the character was first created
by writer / artist keep different when
asked why Lobo became so popular given
answered I have no idea why Lobo took
off I came up with him as an indictment
of the Punisher Wolverine badass hero
prototype and somehow he caught on as
the high violence posted way go figure
but even though he started as parody
Lobos biggest fans didn't really get the
joke or if they did they didn't really
care library became a legitimate fan
favorite but while Wolverine and the
Punisher has become iconic hits in both
comics and on screen and accurate
adaptation of Lobo today would just come
across as a cheap ripoff of Marvel's
characters because well he kind of is as
given said that was the whole point to
misogynistic one of Lobos signature
character traits has been his sexist and
misogynist in one notable comic you
ripped the top off of super heroine
Starfire
against her will as payment for his
help now it was nothing more than a
parody this kind of thing is at least a
little okay
his awfulness and boundary-pushing is
the joke right but it's difficult to
imagine that level of casual sexism
taking place in the same cinematic
universe as Lois Lane and the new black
chicken Wonder Woman you Pig
I like a favorite plays rough if nothing
else
Lobo is a PR nightmare waiting to happen
that whole genocide thing in most
superhero stories the hero is partially
defined by tragedy that goes for Batman
losing his parents or Superman losing
his entire planet these events shape
their entire moral compass and chart
their course towards eventually putting
on a cape Lobo is literally the complete
opposite like Superman he's the light of
his race unlike Superman he didn't lose
you home planet in a moment of tragedy
instead he unleashed a plague that
killed his entire planet
I'm the Lazarus I dragged the rest of
the planet for my high school science
project gave myself a name while we made
sure as Deadpool slices and dices
henchmen we know his victims are
actually bad guys who contributed to a
mutant trafficking ring killing an
entire planet on the other hand is
pretty over-the-top for most villains
let alone goofy anti-heroes inconsistent
power level one of the basic rules of
storytelling is that characters must
somehow be vulnerable
this helps them face various crises and
grow over the course of a story when
superheroes have no apparent
vulnerabilities you have to introduce
something that's one of the reasons why
Superman's weakness is kryptonite to
bring him down to earth Lobos powers are
inconsistent at best and ridiculous at
worst is literally unkillable surviving
everything from the vacuum of space to
the literal fires of hell while everyone
can effortlessly go toe-to-toe with
Superman in a fight and at one point he
even gained the ability
to make clothes of himself from a single
drop of blood how do you make a movie
about an all-powerful jerk who wears
leather and writes a space motorcycle oh
yeah Lobo writes a space motorcycle
design throwback Lobo faces a unique
problem when it comes to bond
appearances the character was introduced
in the 1980s and very quickly settled on
his signature look a leather-clad space
biker on Lobos best day it looks like an
extra from the original Mad Max movie
and only zwarst
at first I was scared because it was a
little rough because of their going to
beam me up but it took me in their arms
and told me the Owls of air and that
might be problematic for the DC extended
universe as one of brothers tries to
update the look of its heroes and
villains don't ever change so with all
these issues from a nutty origin to
crazy powers too dated fashion choices
why not just change him well DC tried
that already - when the publisher was
busy reinventing its heroes with visual
and narrative revisions in the new 52
event back in 2011 Lobo got a makeover
of his own the result was a generic a
genre character who turned out to be the
opposite of everything Lobos fans
actually loved the outcry against the
redesign was intense
resulting in petitions angry letters and
really angry internet comments from
Lobos fans if one a brother sticks with
the classic Lobo the movie is pretty
much unmei Keable if they change him
logo fans will go berserk might as well
not bother right thanks for watching
click the would reich hunting subscribe
to our youtube channel plus check out
all this cool stuff we know you love to
you